[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels ich habe heute
weihnachtsplätzchen für euch ihr habt
nämlich gesagt sally faktor mal wieder
weihnachtsplätzchen auf einem kanal und
auf meinem blog gibt es natürlich schon
einige rezepte da können wir euch auch
die playlist anschauen und alle rezepte
in der übersicht heute gibt's was super
einfach ist denn ich finde beim
plätzchenbacken ich habe halt immer ein
paar ausgefallene aufwendige sachen und
dann habe ich noch plätzchen die einfach
super schnell gehen und ganz einfach
sind
heute ist etwas einfaches ich habe
marzipan konfekt gemacht und das ist im
prinzip eine masse die könnt ihr dann
mit dem einst portionierer oder mit so
einem plätzchen portionierer auf die
oblaten drauf geben nach wunsch
dekorieren und dann ziehen sie schon
fertig da kann man wirklich auch mal
sechs bis acht fläche auf einmal machen
und hat in kurzer zeit ganz viele
plätzchen gebacken
ich zeige euch mal ganz restituta für
den konfekt tag verwende ich 200 gramm
marzipanrohmasse eine prise salz 50
gramm puderzucker 2 weiß etwas an ilex
trakt 65 gramm mehl 100 gramm
cranberries 50 g gehackte mandeln 50
gramm pistazien und baku platten mit
etwa 50 mm durchmesser
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die cranberries
die werden jetzt feiern wir hat
[Musik]
die kommen jetzt direkt hier in eine
rührschüssel dann kann ich jetzt noch
die pistazien hacken
[Musik]
kommen die gehackten pistazien hier auch
dazu die man dann sind ja schon gehackt
dann das eiweiß vanille extrakt
puderzucker und salz und auch das nähe
und das marzipan das muss ich jetzt noch
fein reiben und kann dann alle zutaten
kurz miteinander vermischen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die masse aus die ist
richtig schön klebrig erinnert auch so
ein bisschen an lincoln masse und jetzt
nämlich hier diesen plätzchen
portionierer oder ihr könnt einen
esslöffel nehmen oder einen kleinen eis
funktioniere dann die backplane drauf
und dann direkt auf dem blech absetzen
[Musik]
mit dem plätzen portionierer bekommt man
eben direkt so perfekte halbkugeln hin
[Musik]
das plätzchen konfekt kann jetzt direkt
im ofen gebacken werden nach dem backen
das abkühlen und dann können wir schon
dekorieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist das marzipan konfekt gebacken
und abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich
dekoriere ich habe jetzt hier 150 gramm
peter kuvertüre und die wird jetzt
temperiert kbc bereits wasser aufkochen
lassen und den herd wieder abgestellt
und zwei drittel dekorateure gebe ich
jetzt hier übers warmen wasserbad
[Musik]
und das restliche drittel werde ich
jetzt auch noch hacko und es nehme ich
dann gleich zum herunterkühlen der
kuvertüre und so könnt ihr einfach
sicherstellen dass die kuvertüre später
einen schönen glanz bekommt und keinen
grauen schleier
[Musik]
jetzt ist die kuvertüre geschmolzen
jetzt kann ich das restliche drittel
dazu geben und auch das kokosfett und
dann hat die kuvertüre die perfekte
verarbeitung temperatur und so braucht
hier einfach keinen thermometer benutzen
[Musik]
jetzt traurig dass martin rank konfekt
kopfüber in die kuvertüre lass es dann
kurz abtropfen ließ offs blech zurück
und dann besteuert das konfekt noch mit
mandeln und mit gehackten pistazien
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt das maßnahmenkonzept aus
und murat ist gerade nicht da also darf
sabine probieren du bist so eine süße
probieren weiter was ist eigentlich eine
lieblingsplätzchen am geschmack ich
eigentlich die die terrassen mit
marmelade habe ich auch schon ein
bisschen echten liebling lukas mark
gerne sterne also terrassen will man
auch so würde ja einfach so mit neuer
hätte ich vielleicht auch nicht mehr
aber diese mit
[Musik]
ungelöst drin und ich finde da marzipan
geschmacklich gar nicht so dominanten
bin ich auch nicht viel schokolade oben
ich glaube wenn man den massengeschmack
dominanter möchte dann kann man auch
stadtquartiere obendrauf zum beispiel
butter zucker zitrone und groß machen
aber haben sie auch aus der linken aber
ich mag es auch zar peter mit pistazien
und so ein bisschen wie mozart kugeln ja
ich weiß so starben bei der auslosung
mit pistazien hat stört innen drin
finde ich auch gut und auch so saftig
denken wenn du jetzt noch ein paar tage
in einer keksdose aufbewahrt sind die
auch richtig schön saftig wobei ich das
knusprige frattini von der platte ja auf
jeden fall nach sind ja auf jeden fall
nach mexiko und ihr könnt mir immer
schreiben welche plätzchen eure
lieblingsplätzchen das würde mich auch
interessieren und dann gucke ich mal was
ich vielleicht noch alles machen kann
oder was ich im nächsten jahr von euch
aufgreifen
also viel spaß beim nachhaken und bis
zum nächsten mal gespannt
[Musik]